there does and I think you write this in
the book there seems to be a gravity
pulling people towards the Primitive
mindedness to anything political right
religious certain things sure are bottom
heavy you know for our psyche they they
they they they they they have a magnet
that pulls our psyches downwards on the
ladder and and why why does politics
pull our psyches
down on the ladder because it
for for the tens of thousand years that
we were evolving
um you know during human history it was
life or death politics was life or death
and and and so
um it was actually an amazing study
where it's like
um they
challenged like 20 different beliefs of
a person and different parts of the
person's brain and they had an MRI going
different parts of the person's brain
lit up when non-political beliefs were
challenged versus political beasts were
challenged when political beliefs were
challenged when non-political beliefs
were challenged
the
like the the rational like the
prefrontal cortex type areas were lit up
when the political beliefs were
challenged and then I'm getting over my
head here but it's like the parts of
your brain the default mode Network the
parts of your brain associated with like
inter introspection and like your own
identity were lit up and they were much
more likely to change their mind on all
the beliefs the non-political beliefs
when that default mode Network part of
your brain uh lit up you were you were
gonna if anything get more firm in those
beliefs when you when you had them
challenged so
politics is one of those topics that
just it literally literally lights up
different part of our brain it's again I
think we come back to primitive mind
higher mind here it's like it it gets
our higher this is one of the things our
primitive mind comes programmed to care
a ton about and so it's going to be very
hard for us to stay rational and calm
and and looking for truth because we
have all this gravity towards well it's
weird because politics like what is
politics like to talk about it's a bunch
of different issues and each individual
issue if we really talk about tax policy
like why are we being emotional about
this I don't think we're actually that I
mean we're yeah we're emotional about
something else yeah I think what we're
emotional about is
this my side the side I've identified
with is in power and making the
decisions and your side is out of power
and if your side's in power that's
really scary for me because that goes
back to you know the idea of who's
making who's who's pulling the strings
in this tribe right who's and who's the
chief is it your family's patriarch or
is it mine you know like we might not
have food if if we don't win this you
know kind of whatever you know Chief
election so I I think that it's not
about the tax policy or anything like
that and then and then it gets tied to
this like broader I think a lot of our
tribalism has
really coalesced around this we don't
have that much religious tribalism in
the U.S right now they know the the the
Protestants and the Catholics hate each
other we don't have that really right
and honestly you you say people like to
you know say we have racial tribalism
and everything but
uh White cons you know a white even a
kind of a racist white conservative guy
I think takes the black conservative
over the woke white person any day of
the week right now so that's the
strongest it tells me that first
television is way stronger tribalism
right now I think that that that that
white racist guys you know loves the
black
conservative guy compared to the white
wolf guy right there's no so so to me
not again not that racial tribalism
isn't a thing of course it's always a
thing but like political tribalism is
the number one right now so race is
almost a topic for the political
division versus the actual sort of
element of the attractive it's a
political football it's yeah so there
there's uh I mean this is dark because
so this is a book about human
civilization this is a book about human
nature but it's also a book of politics
about politics
um it is just the way you list it out in
the book
it's kind of dark how we just fall into
these left and right checklists
so if you're on the left it's maintained
where we weighed
universal healthcare good mainstream
media fine guns kill people us is a
racist country protect immigrants tax
costs bad climate change awful raise
minimum wage and on the right is the
flip of that reverse where we weighed
Universal Health Care bad mainstream
media bad people kill people not guns
kill people us was a racist country
protect borders test God's good climate
change overblown don't raise minimum
wage I mean it has you almost don't have
to think about any of this well it's
like literally So when you say it's a
book about politics it's interesting
because it it's a book about the
vertical axis right it's specifically
not a book about the horizontal axis and
that I'm not talking I don't actually
talk about any of these issues I I don't
put out an opinion on them
um those are all horizontal right
but when you so my and rather than are
you know having you know another book
about those issues about right versus
left
I wanted to do a book about this other
axis and so on this axis
the reason I had this checklist is that
this is a low part of the low rung
politics world right low wrong politics
is a checklist and that checklist
evolves right like Russia suddenly is
like popular with the right as opposed
to you know it used to be you know in
the 60s the left was the one defending
Stalin like so they'll switch it doesn't
even matter the substance doesn't matter
it's that this is the approved checklist
of the capital P party and this is what
everyone believes that's a low rung
thing the high rungs this is not what
it's like high rung politics you you
tell me your one view on this I have no
idea what you think about anything else
right and you're gonna say I don't know
about a lot of stuff because inherently
you're not going to have that strong an
opinion because you don't have that much
info these are complex things
so there's a lot of I don't know and
people are all over the place
it's that when it you know you're in you
know you're talking to someone who has
been subsumed with low rung politics
when
if they tell you their opinion on any
one of these issues you could just you
know you could just rattle off their
opinion on every single other one and if
and if in three years it becomes
fashionable to to have this new view
they're gonna have it that's you're not
thinking that's Echo that's Echo chamber
culture and I've been using kind of a
shorthand of Centrist to describe this
kind of
a high wrong thinking but people tend to
I mean it seems to be difficult to be a
Centrist or whatever a high run thinker
it's like people want to label you as a
person who's too cowardly to take a
stance yeah
um somehow as opposed to ask saying I
don't know is the first statement the
problem with Centrist is that would mean
that in each of these tax cuts bag tax
cuts good it means that you are saying I
am in I think we should have some tax
cuts but not that many you might not
think that you might actually come do
some research and say actually I think
tax cuts are really important
that doesn't mean oh I'm not a Centrist
anymore I guess I'm a far you know no no
that's why we need the second axis so
what you're trying to be when you say
Centrist is High Rock which means you
might be all over the place horizontally
you might agree with the far left on
this thing the far right on this thing
that you might agree with the centrists
on this thing but but calling yourself a
Centrist actually like is putting
yourself in a prison on the horizontal
axis and um and it's saying that you
know I I whatever the on the on the
different topics I'm right in between
the two policy wise that's not what you
are so yeah that's what we we're badly
missing this other axis yeah I mean I I
still do think it's this
like for me I am a Centrist when you
project it down to the horizontal but
the point is you're missing so much data
by not considering the vertical because
like on average maybe it falls somewhere
in the middle but in reality there's
just a lot of nuance issue to issue that
involves just thinking and uncertainty
and changing in the given the context of
the current geopolitics and economics
and just always considering always
questioning always evolving your views
all of that not just not just about like
oh I think we should be in the center on
this but another way to be in the center
is if there's some phenomenon happening
um you know there's a terrorist attack
you know and one side wants to say this
has nothing to do with Islam and the
other one the other side wants to say
this is radical Islam
right what's in between those is saying
This is complicated and nuanced and we
have to learn more and it probably has
something to do with Islam and something
to do with
um the economic circumstances and
something to do with you know
geopolitics so in in a case like that
you actually do get really unnuanced
when you go to the extremes and all of
the Nuance which is where all the truth
usually is is going to be in the middle
so yeah but there is a truth to the fact
that if you take that Nuance on those
issues like war in Ukraine covered
you're going to be attacked by both
sides yes people who have who are really
strongly on one side or the other hate
Centrist people I've gotten this myself
and you know the this the the slur that
I've had thrown at me is I'm an
enlightened Centrist in a very mocking
way so what are they actually saying
what does enlightened centers mean it
means someone who is you know Stephen
Pinker or Jonathan height gets accused
of is you know that they're
highfalutin you know intellectual world
and they don't actually have any they
don't actually take a side they don't
actually get their hands dirty and they
can be superior to both sides without
actually taking a stand right so I I see
the argument and I disagree with it
because
I firmly believe that the hardcore
tribes they think they're taking a stand
and they're out in the streets and
they're pushing for something I think
what they're doing is they're just
driving the whole country downwards and
I think they're they're hurting all the
causes they care about and so it's not
that it's not that you know it's not
that we need everyone to be sitting
there you know refusing to take aside
it's that you can be far left and far
right but be upper left and upper right